one of New Zealand's most adventurous
and affable inventors is a Scottish
input named Richard little we know
there's probably about five million
people around the world that could
benefit from using the rakes he's one of
two engineers who started Rex bionics my
best friend was diagnosed with motor
sources and like them me to use a
wheelchair in his future I said why
don't we build your robot legs we spend
four years in the garage and we actually
got something working good sitting that
could stand and it could walk we knew
then we would be able to do this so the
thing you'll notice with the Rex of
course right away is its self support
and it's the only device of its kind
like that because of that most of the
people who use brakes or spinal cord
injured although it can be any mobility
impairment if you stand in it if you
push the joystick forward and let it
cool
you'll take one step and stop if you
keep holding it for it'll keep moving
forward okay
what is the red button do that's the
emergency scale all times the custard
press the red bottle okay so if you push
it forward and let it go that's it
you're gonna lean to that site okay
crazy but you really don't have to put
it Eddy
I'm gonna be Michael Jackson impression
this is Jared he lost the use of his
legs in a car accident ten years ago and
is now a wrecks employee customer and
test driver how long would you use it
you today use it for an hour day Oh give
me a couple of days
it's safe and it's general agenda on the
skin as general and the board's when you
sit in a wheelchair all the time you
know you lose bone density it causes
skin issues or bladder and the act of
walking helps resolve it
I've taken at home and walked into my
local bar because all I do you know walk
back in there for the first time ever
drink with my mates standing up around a
ballet there and to the people to borrow
what a trace yeah